herzlich willkommen auf dem kanal der
halo deutsch schule
in diesem video verraten wir dir tipps
und tricks um effektiv deutsch zu lernen
wir wünschen dir viel vergnügen
hallo schön dass du da bist
neue sprache zu lernen kann ganz schön
anstrengend sein
ich gebe dir ein paar tipps mit welchen
du mehr spaß beim lernen hast
hallo
dass du da bist
neue sprache zu lernen kann ganz schön
anstrengend sein
ich gebe dir ein paar tipps mit welchen
du mehr spaß beim lernen hast
außerdem kannst du dir die dinge danach
besser merken
legen wir los
tipp nummer eins
konsumiere bei einem medien auf deutsch
konsumiere deine medien so oft wie
möglich in deutscher sprache
wenn du fährst dann schaue auf deutsch
du fährst dann schaue auf deutsch
zu beginn ist es hilfreich trickfilme
auf deutsch zu schauen
streaming dienste bieten viele filme und
serien in verschiedenen sprachen an
einen großen lerneffekt hat es wenn du
deine lieblingsserie noch einmal auf
deutsch ist
einen großen lerneffekt hat es wenn du
deine lieblingsserie noch einmal auf
deutsch ist
höhere so oft wie nie
wirklich radio auf deutsch
höhere so oft wie möglich radio auf
deutsch
das radio stellst du aber besser neben
die badewanne
sicher ist sicher
im internet findet du übrigens viele
tolle radiosender
suche einfach nach
deutsche radiosender
schon hast du eine große auswahl an
verschiedenen deutschsprachigen sendern
im internet findet du übrigens viele
tolle radiosender
suche einfach nach
radiosender
schon hast du eine große auswahl an
verschiedenen deutschsprachigen sendern
egal ob online oder offline
zeitungen und magazine auf deutsch zu
lesen hilft dir dein deutsch zu
verbessern
egal ob online oder offline
zeitungen und magazine auf deutsch zu
lesen hilft dir dein deutsch zu
verbessern
tipp nummer zwei
lies bücher auf deutsch
manche bücher können ganz schön schwer
zu verstehen sein
ich empfehle dir deshalb viele
liebesromane zu lesen
fragst du dich
ganz einfach
weil die sprache in den sieben romanen
oft sehr einfach ist
die wörter welche du nicht verstehst
kannst du dir in ein notizheft oder auf
karteikarten schreiben
die wörter welche du nicht verstehst
kannst du dir in ein notizheft oder auf
karteikarten schreiben
auf diese weise kannst du diese immer
wieder lernen
tipp nummer drei schreibe auf deutsch
schreibe deine eigenen texte auf deutsch
natürlich kannst du auch versuchen deine
e mails auf deutsch zu schreiben
oder du verfasst deine tagebucheinträge
von jetzt an auf deutsch
tipp nummer vier teile dein wissen
auch wenn dein
nicht perfekt ist kannst du es trotzdem
mit anderen teilen
so hilft du anderen menschen deutsch zu
lernen
auch wenn dein deutsch nicht perfekt ist
kannst du es trotzdem mit anderen teilen
so hilfst du anderen menschen deutsch zu
lernen
gleichzeitig kannst du dein deutsch
weiter verbessern
[Applaus]
tipp nummer fünf trainiere alle vier
fertigkeiten
schnelle erfolge zu erzielen solltest du
an allen vier fertigkeiten parallel
arbeiten
lesen
sprechen
hören
und 3
schnelle erfolge zu erzielen solltest du
an allen vier fertigkeiten parallel
arbeiten
lesen
sprechen
hören
alle bereiche sind wichtig um schnelle
erfolge zu erzielen
und jetzt noch ein paar nützliche tipps
welche dir beim lernen helfen können
tipp nummer 6
mache regelmäßig pause
niemand kann sich stundenlang
konzentrieren
deshalb alle 30 minuten eine kurze pause
niemand kann sich stundenlang
konzentrieren
mache deshalb alle 30 minuten eine kurze
pause
was bewegung zwischendurch hilft sich
auszuruhen und neue energie zu tanken
etwas bewegung zwischendurch hilft dich
wie wäre es mit einem kurzen spaziergang
an der frischen luft
und schon kannst du dich wieder voll auf
das lernen fokussieren
wie wäre es mit einem kurzen spaziergang
an der frischen luft
und schon kannst du dich wieder voll auf
das lernen fokussieren
als die zeit dafür nicht reicht versuche
es mit ein paar übungen zu hause
falls die zeit dafür nicht reicht
versuche es mit ein paar übungen zu
hause
ein wecker kann dir helfen dich an
deinen zeitplan zu halten
becker kann dir helfen dich an deinen
zeitplan zu halten
tipp nummer 7 erstelle einen lernplan
erstelle deinen persönlichen lernplan
dieser hilft dir dein ziel nicht aus den
augen zu verlieren
erstelle deinen persönlichen lernplan
dieser hilft dir dein ziel nicht aus den
augen zu verlieren
und hier noch mein gratis tipp zum
schluss
gib niemals auf und habe spaß am lernen
auf diese weise wirst du deine ziele
leichter erreichen
waren unsere tipps hilfreich für dich
wie hast du deutsch gelernt
schreibe deine lerntipps in die
kommentare
vergiss nicht das video
zu liken
kommentiere und abonniere unseren kanal